what's the deal with Santa so breaking
the entering is okay long as it's a
chubby white dude and easy go mama's
cookies mm-hmm when are you gonna stop
asking me if I pray five times a day
that's so mean
cuz I don't I feel guilty I'm a super
bacon in everything
bacon it feels doughnuts come on now
this is water safe to drink there's
bacon in this water huh do you really
think when wearing a hijab don't have
hair underneath you think that when you
see someone with a beanie a hat a hoodie
why do you think all Muslims are Arab
there are 1 billion people in the Middle
East that's geographically physically
intellectually impossible why are only
Muslims mentioned and talks about
religious extremism did you all forget
about the KKK Westboro Baptist Church
Crusades why do you assume all Muslim
women are conservative virginal Souls
and I am if my mom's watching why do you
expect every Muslim woman to wear a
headscarf does every Catholic woman
dressed like a nun does every Jewish man
wear a yarmulke
is every Streck wear a tunic are you
really scared that I'm gonna take over
America with Sharia law I can barely
wake up for Foggia let alone ways a holy
war you really think I want to donate
2.5 percent of my income to charity
ah that's hella McChicken what is the
secret ingredient in church's chicken
it's so good how can I hang out with the
new Pope because he is dope